in an exclusive interview with al
Jazeera the spokesperson for Iraq's
Hezbollah brigades has confirmed a
meeting in Iran of all the major Shia
armed groups in the region it was held
in the city of Qom and he said they
chalked out the future course of action
against quote u.s. aggression let's find
out what more he had to say from Osama
bin je vais joining us from baghdad
osama but there in in this exclusive
interview their spokesman mohammed gaje
of Kedah Hezbollah or Hezbollah brigades
group is opening up for the first time
in front of the media after the attacks
which took place on the border between
Iraq and Syria and then the attack on
the US Embassy and the ensuing targeting
of the commander of the popular
mobilization forces of the media
Mohandas and Qasem Soleimani
as well as the attacks that followed
that off by Iran in an wide-ranging
interview he did tell us about this
important meeting which took place in
the city of palm between what he called
forces which are aligned to the
resistance in Iraq and forces which are
the Shia militia fighters not just in
Iraq but across the region he said they
answered the call of modest other and
they all sat down and you will see that
as a result of outcome one of the
outcomes of this meeting is going to be
protests which are going to happen in
Baghdad in a few days we're both adults
had that is called for a Million Man
March about the future course of action
against US forces he said the Qatari
Hezbollah Hezbollah brigades group has
the capability of striking the US forces
whenever in however it wants but it is
going to follow the Iraqi government's
decision to make sure that they expel
u.s. and foreign troops out of Iraq he
refused to confirm that it was them who
were behind the Kirkuk attack which
resulted in an attack on them on the
iraq-syria border but he did say they
have the capabilities including drone
capabilities and I asked them whether it
was they were chosen bypassing Soleimani
to carry out these attacks inside Iraq
Lisa Fahad Kitab Hezbollah not only cut
Bolla in iraq will face the US troops
and not only Kataeb has the ability for
confrontation but the whole iraqi people
will face down these troops it is true
that Kataeb has high capabilities and
high training due to its history in
fight against the US occupation it's
also due to accumulated knowledge in
fighting ISIL after 2014
maybe Kataeb was the best and only force
to deal with different kinds of weapons
especially those modern weapons and
dealing with US weapons this may have
made katayev a target but we say that we
are ready and prepared to fight against
anything Iraq faces it will not be alone
in the confrontation the whole Iraqi
people and the resistance groups all of
them will be confronting the US troops
and this is a group which has been
designated a terrorist organization by
the United States I asked them whether
they're in hiding after these threats
and they said they are operating out in
the open
he'd met us in the middle of the street
he said they are here they are here to
stay and on another note about the
protestors who've been asking for an end
to the influence of Iran and the United
States he said that the he and the Kitab
as well our group is against the
presence of any foreign forces whether
those are American troops or Iranian
troops all right Osama thank you for
bringing that for us from Baghdad